Наша первостепенная задача - определить
тип кожи, светодип и состояние кожи. Для
чего нам нужно определить тип кожи?
У каждого типа кожи есть опутствующие
проблемы в состоянии кожи.
Такие люди постоянно страдают разжжжжж
ными поворами, воспалительными процессами,
виде окна, покрояснения, разражения, жжжж
енные болезками, донукрии и большое
количество проблем их беспокоит.
Для чего нужно определять это тип? Чем тем
нее кожи, тем белика, веридность того, что
вашей пациентки, после каких-то химических
оживоков, неважно поверхностные среди.
Также к лазерных процедур может появиться
пигментация.
Теперь по состоянию кожи есть воспалитель
ные процессы, в основном они в области зонул
бан, ближе к роста волос, расширенные поворы
, жженные блеск, черные точки, соответ
ственно процедура назначается только по
состоянию кожи.
Сегодняшняя наша тема посвящена пигантом
до опил. По состоянию кожи мы выбираем тип
цен.
Стягивают поворы, нормализуют работы саль
ных желез, снимает жженные блеск, препятств
ует воспаление и образование черных точек,
улучшает состояние проблемной кожи и
способствует красаванию рупсоп.
Перед пиленбом проводится все необходимые
процедуры, очищения, тонизация кожи, распар
ивания для расширения пор.
Предварительно мужу кожу очистили гелемд
омывания, так как тип кожи у нас жженные.
Распариваем кожу буквально течение одной,
двух минут.
После каждого контакта с водой обязательно
тонизируем кожу.
Тонар подбирается по состоянию кожи.
В данном случае мы подбираем тонн именно ан
тибактериальным, предназначен для проблем
ной кожи.
Постанавливает оптимальный паше кожи
после умывания и повышает эффективность
дальнейшего ухода.
Главные действующие компоненты тоннеры -
это экстракт разного чайного дерева.
Особая бытишка из центелла азиатской, лакт
абионовая кислота и не оценамид.
Ампул оладин состоят из двух частей.
И при перемешивании образуется зеленоват
ая масса, получившийся состав необходимо
разогреть плодоним и нанести на кожу паци
ента.
Чтобы улучшить проникновение компонентов,
мягко втирать состав массажными движения
ми,
одним слоем по всему лицу, начиная от албам,
по гостиноса, щок, подбородка равномерно.
Для одной процедуры достаточно одной ампул
в упаковке и в 10 штук.
Во время пацидуры на кожу может поздник
нуть покалыванием припухлась покраснения
кожи.
Эти симптомы пройдут течение 24-48 часов.
Для эффективного резюхата, понаблюдением
наших практиковщих сметологов, также самих
пациентов, чем сильнее втирать припарат
кожу тем она эффективнее.
Пилин к дуопил предназначен только для
профессионального применения.
Ее применяют специалисты в условиях коснет
ологического кабинета, не в коем случае
своим пациентам, пилиентам, надам, пилин в
ней даем.
Для того-то баслоить материал можно много
учиться изучать каждой компонент и состав.
В основу пилин к дуопил именно тип цель леж
ит переработанная кока нажалка пряда.
Они содержат огромное количество аминок
ислот, минерал, белки, фибраин и серитин.
Этот комплекс веществ положительно влияет
на процесса восстановления и обновления
кожи.
Заживая трубцы и ранки, помогает убрать
проблемные высыпания, очищает и сужает пор
а, успокаивает воспаленные участки, оказыв
ает увлажняющие омолаживающие действия.
Именно пилин дуопил тип цель, рекомендован
людям жирные и комбинированные кожей с рас
ширенными порами, с пломностью, воспалитель
ным процессом.
После пилинка кожа будет шелушиться, шелуш
ение пройдёт течения 1-2 недель.
Нужно избегать антактор с водой течении 24
часов после процедуры.
Далее при умывании с пользуете прохладную
воду, а не теплую, окажитесь от посещения б
ани, сауну, бассейна на одну, терее 2 недели
после пилинка.
Перед выходом на улицу обязательной
используете солнечитные средства. Солнеч
итные средства действуют течении 1-3 часов,
поэтому по необходимости повторяйте на нес
ине.
Не забывайте об увлажнении позже, применяй
те тоннер, увлажняющие в сывороте и крема.
Течении 3-7 дней на позже ни в коем случае
нельзя наносить средства с ретенолом с к
ислотами.
Избегайте вредной пищи и алкоголя.
Для завершения процедуры рекомендуем на
носить маску целлюлозную для завершения
процедуры для того, чтобы успокоить кожу.
Особенно маска рекомендована - девушкам
поврежденные позже после пилинголазинного
вода и других травмирующих процедур.
Поэтому он подходит как идеальное заверш
ение процедуры для того, чтобы быстро усп
окоить кожу после пилинголуопил.
Активные компоненты маски - это 5 видов пеп
тидах, диалерона-эксотам, экстракт аустных
культуру виноградом, культуру лотоса, з
еленого чайя, центела азиатской, экстракт г
омомелисом и алантоин.
Маска выполнена из натуральной цириллоза.
Распределите маску в полицию равномедна,
расправьте ее, маску можно продержать до 20-
30 минут, затем по краям остатки или аккурат
но очищаете по росту волос, ложнее салфет
кой и остатки мы тонизируем.
Там, где контактировали водой, еще раз обр
абатываете кожу антибактериальным тонн
ером, для того, чтобы успокоить кожу и зав
ершающий таб, мы наносим антибактериальный
крем.